Okay guys, in this problem we have another quick concept question being asked of us.
So which of the following statements is true about the footings in the cantilevered structure
shown?
So we can see that we have a cantilevered structure with footing 1, footing 2, a load applied
on the right hand side at the top, and a wind load.
So the Question is, for the list of options we can select would be, footing 1 will
be subjected to uplift loading, footing 2 will be subjective to compressive loading, footing
1 will be subjected to compressive loading, footing 2 will be subjected to uplift loading,
both footings will be subjected to uplift loading, or both footings will be subjected to
compressive loading,
And so if we're looking at the way that the force is going to be applied on this structure,
it's going to cause a rotation this direction essentially.
So this footing is going to be subjected to an uplift force, while this footing is going
to be subjected to a compressive force.
So our answer in this case is just going to be the first one here.
And that's it.
If you didn't know this answer, you could look back at various structural analysis
questions or basic static questions, which might help you to study.
And if you don't know an answer on the test, you can always leave it blank and come back
to it later if you have time to guess.